it's a special moment in the history of
all of computing it's
uh we'll talk about it later but it's
arguable it's possible that the entirety
of the world will run in javascript at
some point
so like it's like those are those days
it would be
it would be interesting if you could
just describe actually zooming in
on the how the cake was baked
uh from the you know the the several
days that you were working on it
what was in your mind uh how much coffee
were you drinking
or you're nervous why you're freaking
out i'll try to remember it i mean
you're right there are these pregnant
moments you see in hindsight maybe
they're
overrated but like hegel sees napoleon
on horseback
right yana and says there's the world
spirit uh on
on horse um and uh
i knew that there was a chance to do it
mark knew
and he was my you know executive sponsor
and
he was the one you know sort of
brainstorming how the javascript should
be right there in the page that was
important for him to say that because i
i thought so too but
a lot of people were like well you can't
write programming language in the middle
of the markup
and indeed there are problems if you did
it naively you'd see the code
laid out as like random gibberish so i
had to figure out how to hide that that
was a
challenge is that is it a breakthrough
idea i mean
so you mark thinking about this idea
that you just inject
code in the middle of the market the web
page yeah it was considered kind of
heretical there was an sgml guru i
forget his name but he corresponded with
me and at first he was angry he's like
you should have used a marked section
why didn't you use a marked section and
i said well
html marked sections are not part of
html by the way and they're not
supported in the browser
and so i did some hack that was
equivalent and over time you could do
the proper sgml thing
but it eventually came around and it was
again sort of
evolutionary necessity it was almost
like introgression like like you know
the idea
um which lin margulies i think
helped get across that uh we have to
consider
mutualism in biology that maybe you know
mitochondria were ancient uh
prokaryotes that got into the cell and
became beneficial
um somehow uh the same sort of thinking
applies uh you have to embed javascript
in html it's going to be a good virus
it won't the code becomes data in a
sense it just gets carried
it's very carried along but yeah is
there is there's
the side of the so you were focusing on
an escape at that time
doesn't the browser have to support
interpret correctly this
mix of html yeah and whatever code i had
to hide it from old browsers including
netscape one one which was predominant
then
so i used an html comment but the
inside the container that comment lived
in the script tag which is a new element
i could make
different semantics in netscape too
where those
html comment delimiters instead of being
multi-line brackets became one line
or essentially one line so you wrote the
javascript was written the programming
language is written as a comment
a comment for all browsers and a set of
brackets that were ignored with real
code for new
and it was this two-way comment hiding
hack as i called it
that was absolutely necessary for us to
get off the ground we couldn't have
bootstrapped javascript without it
we didn't have scripts that were loaded
from a separate file the only scripts in
netscape 2 were inline in the document
what were the challenges here what what
like what uh
you know typing uh what were the choices
you were thinking about garbage
have time to write a garbage collector
so i just i didn't at first so the thing
was using
essentially arenas or what gnu calls obj
pools and
just would run out of memory eventually
and i added reference counting in a
hurry
after the 10 days in which i hacked so
after i was in the server team doing
http 101
and thinking about the language i
finally got transferred to the client
team in early may and that's when i
you know i got the go sign from mark and
it was like we can't wait because people
inside netscape are doubting
even people uh inside sun are definitely
doubting bill joy was the champion but
he was like
alone in that in seeing there was a role
for javascript as the
as i call it the sidekick language robin
the boy hostage
frank miller put it in the dark knight
returns um
that uh there was this silly little
language that would be the blue language
it could become important over time and
and you were better off having that
complementarity that pairing of
languages just like microsoft stacked it
with visual c plus plus and visual basic
so what was the big
moment of uh i'm done so i had to do a
demo i
i forgot the dates i think i for a
history of programming languages paper
that alan where's brock
did with my health he did a lot of the
writing um i think it was the
10 days from like thursday evening
through to the following weeks you know
the whole of that week and then into the
monday not not enough and i was really
uh
going fast because i had already used a
lot of um
c compiler and front-end compiler
knowledge that i'd gained
from undergraduate school when i started
getting into computing
as a renegade physics major uh people
were formalizing
more efficient uh bottom-up grammars
parsers for bottom
languages uh really uh lalr one was the
big thing
and i studied all this and learned how
to parse them and
in the end uh if you're doing c
languages you often do what um
what what uh dennis ritchie did anyway
which is the recursive descent
uh parser you can hand code it and um
i did that for javascript in a blazing
hurry
mostly got it right i didn't you know
have precedence inversion problems or
other bugs but i copied a lot
from java and c and i tried to keep
things simple like the equality operator
in those 10 days sprint between
two objects of different dynamic type
said no they're not equal their types
are different
and then after that i had internal early
adopters and they were using javascript
to
like match a number against a database
field that had been stringized and they
said oh can we just have implicit
conversion and
like an idiot i agreed i gave them what
they wanted i was trying to please them
and get adoption
and that you know broke what
what equivalence relation um nature
there was to
the double equal you know there's some
for edge cases with not a number that
break that up too but
it really broke it um having implicit
conversions in the operator is something
that people still
roast me over
you